[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welthandel kekse und dafür braucht ihr
wirklich für die mantel kekse verwende
ich 150 gramm eiweiß eine prise salz 150
gramm puderzucker 25 gramm mehl
bittermandel aroma etwas vanille extrakt
geschälte mandeln 150 gramm und ich habe
ich noch gehobelte mandeln das sind 75
gramm ok habe jetzt alle zutaten die
mandeln die sind wie gesagt broschiert
das heißt geschält ihr könnt natürlich
auch gemahlene mandeln nehmen ich machte
sitzt hier allerdings ganz kurz im mixer
geben hier den mandeln rhein und die
hälfte des futters und dieser mira die
hat immer gesagt butter zucker als sie
noch kleiner bruder zucker und jetzt
schön fein mahlen und das geht eben
besser wenn man zucker mit den mandeln
vermalt denn wenn man richtig starken
mixa hat kann es nämlich passieren dass
man handeln muss bekommt und nicht
mandeln dahin und plus
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier in dieser
schüssel das eiweiß schlagen mit der
brisanz
[Musik]
kommt jemanden puderzucker mischung hier
rein ich sie dir jetzt noch
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch etwas vanille
extrakt mit dazu dann ein paar tropfen
bittermandel aroma
[Musik]
dann das mehl mit rein im prinzip
erinnert so ein bisschen an macarons und
jetzt unterheben nein eigentlich
unterscheidet sich dieses rezept
macarons nur durch das meer
[Musik]
die masse fülle ich jetzt direkt hier in
einen spritzbeutel mit einer großen loch
hülle beziehungsweise mittelgroß der
mittelgroßen 1 cm ungefähr wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr die masse sogar noch
einfärben
aber ich finde dann erinnert es wirklich
so sehr am makarov und jetzt kleine
tupfen aufs backblech beziehungsweise
auf die back folie spritzen
[Musik]
okay die wurden bei mir immer größer
aber ist jetzt nicht schlimm aber wenn
ihr sie gleichmäßiger machen wollen dann
nimmt am besten ein backpapier zeichne
auf die rückseite kreise ein und dann
habt ihr sie gleich groß
die mandelblättchen die zeit drücke ich
bisschen in der hand und bestreut dem
man die masse damit und dann kommen sie
schon direkt in den backofen
[Musik]
so sehen die tickets aus und ich habs
jetzt auch schön abkühlen lassen
ihr könnt sie jetzt entweder füllen mit
einer leckeren marmeladen oder mit
marzipan und ich habe mich wirklich
gerade kurz vorher dazu entschlossen
wahrzunehmen
ihr könnt aber auch schon mal was
vorbereitet und zwar hier 100 gramm
peter kuba tierisch schmelzen über einem
warmen wasserbad
das ist es schon geschehen deswegen
nehme ich jetzt herunter und gebe ich
hier jetzt nochmal 50 gramm profiteure
dazu so kommt die kuvertüre nämlich auch
die perfekte temperatur wird also
abgekühlt und dann entsteht später kein
grauschleier
[Musik]
und tricks einfach hier rein und dann
kommt wie bei einem apéro noch der
zweite teil obendrauf
[Musik]
also die kekse jetzt fertig aber ich
muss schon fast weinen und meine 32 et
wichtel sie dürfen jetzt probiert offen
[Gelächter]
effekt macht aber es tut nicht nur sorg
lachen und wie man den effekt 123 so und
wenn es euch schmeckt machtlos ich
wollte eigentlich eben intro sagen also
dieses plätzchen rezepte ist wirklich
eine tolle resteverwertung vor allem hat
man ja beim plätzchenbacken oftmals nur
einen immer eigelb und dann bleibt das
eiweiß übrig und jedes jahr nur
kokosmakronen ist auch langweilig also
könnt ihr gerne diese plätzchen backen
und ich meinen theoretisch kommen sie
auch glutenfrei zubereiten das bisschen
mädels kam auch weglassen ein kleines
jetzt können wir diesen kommentar warum
riecht sanierer an allem respekt vor
allem ist das ist also ein tolles
plätzchen rezept nachmachen
ja und jetzt finde ich müssen wir
entweder war es zweckmäßig machen
weihnachtswichtel mäßig oder was wir
können ja so hey hey hey hey hey hey
zwerge hoch
[Musik]
aha
ok hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
hatte gibt es ein leckeres plätzchen
rezept und zwar ist es so eine
abwandlung auf macarons pcs ich habe
vergessen was ich sagen soll
wenig sagt normal ok daher am hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres plätzchen
rezept und zwei sonne zusammen stunden
herunter
[Gelächter]
hallo